[Musik]
in einem sind sich alle einig es muss
endlich schluss sein mit der großen
koalition
wir nehmen deshalb alles strapazen auf
uns und reisen martin schulz einen tag
lang durchs ganze bundesgebiet hinterher
ich sammle unterschriften dass die spd
wieder in die opposition geht um die spd
zu retten
ich bin aber bundeskanzler wie hat das
filmbüro position
doch natürlich später irgendwann wir
müssen die spd retten haben sie darauf
pocht darauf dass die spd immer
irgendwann so wieder was sowieso ein
profil bekommt ja durchaus aber hat sie
ja eigentlich jetzt wieder mit martin
schulz soziale gerechtigkeit so war es
eigentlich eine person macht leider noch
kein profil das ist richtig aber gut ich
werde es gibt ja viele junge leute in
der spd so wie ich mein junge leute
machen auch noch kein profil ja aber die
wir bemühen uns redlich wieder ein zu
bekommen wie wäre es mit inhalten
inhalten sind gut ja herr schulz ich bin
ja auf ihrer seite ich möchte die spd
auch retten er tatsächlich aber ich
glaube nur dass das mit einer gruppe
nicht möglich ist wie wärs denn
folgendermaßen sie wollen herr
bundeskanzler werden
wie wäre es so sie werden
oppositionsführer aber wir sagen ihnen
alle sie sind bundeskanzler das gute
idee wir machen so wir müssen uns
beeilen martin schulz einholen das wird
diese wahl wohl das einzige kopf an kopf
rennen auf geht's
[Musik]
rocco macht neun von zehn menschen doof
ist es so gehen bis zu nein die macht
nicht berufen das kann man doch nicht
alle neun von zehn gruppe verursacht
erektiler dysfunktion auch bei frauen
damit habe ich nichts zu tun ich greife
zu anderen mitteln
sie werden ganz müde die krokos börse
sie gehen nicht in die koalition mit der
cdu
sie gehen in die opposition bei mir ist
das immer so wenn ich den welt gesehen
da war ich auf wenn ich sie da schlafe
ich ja wenn sie wenn sie so schlagfertig
sind warum waren sie das nicht im tv
duell macht es auch egal
hinterher
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in der großen koalition geht die spd ja
leider immer kaputt so ein bisschen wie
in der ehe da gibt es immer den einen
partner der so ein bisschen der chef ist
und der andere der sich also die jahre
durchschlägt sind die verheiratet sind
sie verheiratet ja okay und geben sie
mir recht stolz da bin ich wieder ich
wollte noch mal ein autogramm wenigstens
haben ein letztes autogramm jetzt schon
mal der stift und hier das schild von
deutschem boden soll nie wieder eine
gruppe aus dem
ja unterschreiben wollte hat es noch
nicht aber dafür hat man meinen kopf
berührt ich werde nicht nur wieder
waschen da wird doch kanzler ich glaube
jetzt wieder zurück ins studio
[Applaus]
[Musik]
von jörg pastoor und damit